kid houston spoke the new corner about
how the heat takes lives
every year hey kate yes ted dehydration
and prolonged heat exposure can quickly
put you in the hospital
it can even kill you so far 12 people
have died this year
due to the heat now it is still early
here in the summer in the southwest
last year heat was the main factor in
124 deaths in clark county
coroner melanie rouse previously worked
in the phoenix area so she's familiar
with how the heat can impact the body
she says what's unique about vegas is
the high amount of visitors that come
who are not ready for the high
temperatures i think it's more about
communicating to the public the
importance of
utilizing those mitigation strategies
it's about communicating that to the
visitors in our community
that may not be familiar with how hot
that really is
making sure that we're providing them
with adequate water stations providing
them with the information that they need
to protect themselves
rouse says a crucial and sometimes
challenging part of their investigation
is the initial information given they
have to piece together if a person was
acclimated to the heat
and understand if they had resources
available to help keep them cool
now if you do go outside in these hot
temperatures doctors recommend having
plenty of water
wearing light colored clothing and
taking frequent breaks it also helps to
know the signs
of heat exhaustion and heat stroke
reporting live kate houston 8 news now